[Musique]
avez vous un sentiment d'accomplissement
à queue à la gare
à tous les égards êtes vous satisfait
un nouveau chapitre de ma vie vient de
commencer
et je sens déjà le fardeau de la
couronne que je porte
j'ai été contraint de suivre les
conseils d'un homme dont la loyauté ne
me semblaient jamais acquise
j'ai besoin de mon tour et d'hommes en
qui j'ai eu ma fier
je suis venu parce que tu es mon ami
un roi n'a pas d'amis un roi n'est
entouré que de partisans
et adversaires
mais je serai à tes côtés l'envi aurora
[Musique]
on parle plus vite que ça toi d'abord je
m'appelle sarah connor le 29 août 1997
devait être le jour du jugement dernier
mon fils john et moi avons empêché sa et
sauver 3 milliards de vies c'est
suffisant comme cv a des yeux
pas vraiment
tu as peut-être changer l'avenir mais
t'as pas changer notre destin c'est quoi
au juste
j'en avais jamais vu des comme toi
presque humaine je suis humaine mais
améliorées que les choses soient claires
j'ai pour mission de la protéger si tu
la mets en danger
je te crève la peau procès je prends le
volant
je vais faire un gros but pour passer je
suis une vraie arme ambulance
épargnez-nous des phrases de drague
désolé
[Applaudissements]
je reviendrai
écoute c'est par malheur tu ne t'en sors
pas tout le monde va mourir
comment on arrête ce truc on ne le
combat pas
on le fuit
chara est ce que tu crois au destin si
on gagne pas cette fois
tout est fichu
tu sais quand on en aura fini je te
tuerais
c'était un grand honneur parce que les
beatles y était allé vous qui ça eleanor
rigby annonce un connaître la marine
tintin sociaux marine
c'est idiot c'est très amusant si vous
démissionnez ce sera pris comme un
véritable affront façon de vivre est un
affront vos chaussures sont en avant
vous n'avez pas mes chaussures
[Musique]
gala vous ne voyez plus en plus partie
intégrante de ce monde
le plus difficile dans tout ça c'est
d'écouter d'entendre sa voix la voix du
seigneur
pas moi qui ai besoin d'être satisfait
c'est un milliard deux cents millions de
croyants c'est vous savez il ya un
dicton dieu puis toujours un pape en
offrant au monde son successeur
j'aimerais que ma punition arrive
anoh a dit white noise à 10 microns
et vous ne pas l'être interview sa mort
nous aimerions vous savez cette fille
vraiment vraiment vraiment grande qui va
dans la même école que vous tu me
demandais si tu voudrais pas eh ben
c'est moi non laisse tomber c'était rien
d'important 16 ans 1 m 85 et demi alors
il fait qu'elle tourna au joli tout
survêtement espèce de yéti et toi tu as
dit qu à ma copine fayda arrêts il faut
juste que tu sois courageuse face à
l'adversité
oui j'adore c'est celle qu'il te faut
c'est parfait je trouve ça fou que tu
veuilles pas sortir avec moi tu penses
qu'à tout moment un gars sont plus
grands que toi le mec parfait quoi va
entrer par cette porte
[Musique]
j'y vais aussi
les vins
bien sûr que non garçon a passé la
douanière fois une heure où elle est
déjà en train de marquer son territoire
alors ça te plaît pour l'instant la
mairie pour l'instant j'aime beaucoup
l'amérique
un séjour jody tu leur fera face et tu
leur diras j'aime chaque centimètre de
mon mètre 85 à l'eau bonsoir je suis
l'étudiant étranger ton école j'espérais
que tu voudrais venir avec mon bol de la
rentrée oui je vais voir les choses en
face c'est la géante
j'aimerais juste que tu te sens n'en à
pas chaque fois que tu essaies de me
faire sentir normal je finis toujours
par me sentir encore plus différente
j'ai besoin de ton dieu dieu j'y crois
pas j'ai attendu que ce jour arrive
toute ma vie je vais te transformer de
fond en comble alors mettons-nous au
travail que vous dites c'est qu'un rouge
à lèvres et un gloss ces deux choses
différentes
paredes pressé
je ressemble au canapé de mamie ou à une
sublime princesse sirène voilà ça c'est
moi la nouvelle jeudi me plaît jodie qui
affronte c'est par jodie qui obtient ce
qu'elle veut je suis amoureux de cette
fille de prix l'école élémentaire et
voilà qu'il ya un nouveau qui arrive est
une ruine ses ventes de stratégie
[Musique]
tu es en train de draguer mon mec c'est
pas vrai ne t'approche pas de lui dako
arrêté d'accord avec tout ce que je dis
ok on a tous quelque chose qu'on
aimerait pouvoir changer chez soi c'est
ma très grande petite ça c'est moi tout
ce qu'on peut faire c'est décider de la
façon dont on fait avec
quand tu es une grande fille c'est
vraiment la seule chose que les gens
voient c'est pas la seule chose que je
vois
juste fait en sorte que tu sois pas
blessé
[Musique]
je connais londres il ya plein de gens
prêts à payer pour avoir du lourd et
rocco oui et plein d'autres trucs
tu as compris jamaïque
j'ai ce contact
[Musique]
les chiens se démerde bien on sera au
top
qu'est ce que t'en dit
et cela il est revenue à sommers
et devient avec qui douchaient il
ils vont g jour du matos diouf on est de
retour
les choses ont changé dans quoi alors
c'est moi qui dirige ce [ __ ] de gangs
n'ont fait gaffe personne vient chercher
dans merde à semmar à dieu et demi ce
soir alors laisse moi te donner un petit
conseil les conseils je les donne moi tu
veux dit les tu vends ma d'eau ou alors
tu tires à pédales
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce gars on sait qu'il a deux
frères gémit il fait quoi
j'aime et qui formaient
tu sais que je suis hyper fier de toi et
moi t'es pas fier de moi
[Musique]
depuis qu'on est gamins avec tous les
deux à courir partout dans les rues
on a essayé d'atteindre le sommet et
pour faire ça il faut qu'on se
débarrasse tu me voulait fumer
[Musique]
pas confiance dans ce milieu je te fais
confiance pour agir justement
quoi qu on dise pour arriver à temps
pour ce que tu veux tu dois battre si tu
retrouves que celles qui vont de faire
le sommet
ça vaut le coup de perdre ce qu'on aime
sa famille
quelles options pourraient avoir dix
mois
[Musique]
cette chose me suis dans mes cauchemars
depuis mon enfance
quelque chose
bon marianne c'est une sorcière
privé de corps et l'air elle investit
tout mais j'ai écrit ces bouquins pour
lutter contre elles et comment les aider
[Musique]
depuis le début elle est dans ma tête
je te préviens
je n'ai pu lire
et je respecte toujours mes promesses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
me car qu'est ce qu'elles attendent va
bientôt se réveiller
comment se passe ton stage d'assistant
scission harry est un danger pour son
entourage et pour elle même elle a
besoin d'être encadré
attendez
tu crois qu'un cheval peut changer
quelqu'un elle est pas mis gains et
coarraze y doucement avec le volant au
caire ressemble peut-être un peu mika
canopus ou et arrêts at elle déjà mangé
elle croit que cheval est toi qui es tu
je suis la cousine de sam
bienvenue à calton bar ni cas ne se
réveille pas parce que wii sports va mal
et whisper ne mange pas parce que mika
va mal de vous trouver un remplaçant à
mika personne ne remplacera mika tu veux
manger
mais qui es tu toi je suis la cousine de
sam et vous le grand père de sam
les chevaux sont sensibles aux énergies
tu dois apprendre à contrôler la tienne
pourriez-vous mia prends mais tu ne
pourras pas monter whisper il a perdu
beaucoup de force depuis qu'il refuse de
manger
il a mangé mes carottes
[Musique]
les en danger se bouscule ça nous
aiderait tout l'été
le guerrier et son cheval ne font qu'un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mecha et toi vous êtes très différentes
mais ensemble vous êtes prête à tous les
combats
[Musique]